saints 10-2 clinching their fourth
straight playoff berth and trying to do
what they did back in 2009 finish it all
with the super bowl championship he is
sean payton coach welcome back how are
you
good mike thanks for having me on oh
it's great to talk to you as always and
i talked to your current starting
quarterback taysom hill after the game
on sunday
he
made it clear
to me that the latest episode of the
don't eat the cheese prop includes
baskets of cheese that were given to all
players putting their lockers that that
sounds like a hell of a lot of cheese
that you had to track down
every once in a while there's a request
and i don't know
i don't know sometimes how they're
fulfilled they just get fulfilled
you know there was a company on the on
the bugs bunny road runner called acme
and a truck would just pull up but
anyway it came
look it came during that thanksgiving
break and i thought look there's a
message behind it and then also
they can bring back a basket of some
crackers mustard cheese etc uh to their
house um
but look these guys these guys have been
responding they understand each week
they understand the challenges each week
uh especially in this league and and
that's
you're trying to think of unique ways
um
to just make sure they're they're
working on that game
and and not
any other
how much do you have to remind yourself
of that you're rocking toward the post
season again first team to officially
clinch this year we know what's happened
each of the last three years you don't
need me to remind you of it how much do
you have to keep yourself from
from peeking ahead thinking ahead
looking ahead and and follow the your
own don't eat the cheese mantra
yeah i listen i think it's different for
coaches i know it's different for me and
i
and i can only say this and i
early in the week like today tuesday
we're game planning now on philly in in
in and going through
first and second down third down and
um
for me
at the beginning in the middle of each
week the team we're getting ready to
play looks like the 85 bears
in other words
their new challenges they're new
problems we have to come up with
solutions uh you're unsettled a little
bit because you want to make sure you
have the right plan is this the right
way to attack this team
there are a lot of those
questions racing through your mind and
as the week progresses those begin to
get calmed down you begin to
maybe get more and more
not confident but more and more of an
understanding more and more clarity
relative to what you want to do and
and so it is that it is that short term
um
the whole day today is first and second
down and
yesterday i'll take a peek always at the
at the league touchdown reel
and record basically every touchdown
that's scored and run and pass and and
and then some other special situations
that come up
and kind of keep a file of that just so
you're not losing track of a good idea
something that you know looked pretty
good and and it may come up in a in a
game if not that week maybe down the
road but um but back to your question i
i
i think
i think it's our jobs as coaches
sometimes to hey haul them in bring them
in and say look this is here here are
the things that that can beat us this
week and this is what this team does
well
and
and you have to understand every week
man we're playing an nfl team
and these are the things that they do
exceptionally well and uh so i think
it's a little easier for us not to get
ahead
um and and the important thing is
communicating that to everyone
you did a masterful job a few weeks ago
of keeping close to the vest the
identity of your starting quarterback
after drew brees was injured
this week you're preparing to face an
eagles team that has yet to announce its
starter whether it be carson wentz will
it be jalen hurts how much of that
is a practical impediment to your
efforts to game plan when you don't know
who the starter is going to be
i think it's a good question i think in
their case and this would be just my
opinion
both
both of those quarterbacks have
athleticism that can beat you
outside the pocket they can beat you
with the
the off schedule throws
when they allude
they can throw on the run very well
i i think
look i think sometimes when there's a
dramatic difference between a and b
um you'd like to know earlier in your in
your planning and yet
you know generally speaking uh
when you're when you're defending a team
you're defending an offense but there
can be some subtle differences
and when player x
goes goes out we've all seen this before
in game a player get hurt and a game has
a certain flow to it and then another
player comes in at that position
particularly quarterback and all of a
sudden it's like what happened
and and there's a different flow to it
sometimes that can be from
from the skill set variation from one to
two
i have a question for you that very
possibly is a stupid question but that's
never stopped me in the past one of my
theories for why you kept it quiet a few
weeks ago between taysom hill and jameis
winston it made it a bigger issue it
made it a bigger game it made it more of
a focus and necessarily put a little
more pressure on taysom was that part of
the motivation to test him a little bit
to see how he would hold up when
everyone is paying attention to what he
does
well look
that was going to be a big game for him
regardless it was going to be his first
start and
um yeah was there
a certain amount of pressure on him in
that game i absolutely i felt that
myself even as the head coach or the
play caller
because look people don't want to be
wrong people
expect certain things to happen and then
all of a sudden it's it's
it's it's something else then it's like
well why is that happening and uh and so
look the very first play of the game was
a was a bunch with mike thomas motioning
out to the to the numbers and in a
little sprint pass
and tayson's wound up and gets out there
and we line up and bunch and he snaps
the ball and returned i said what
happened to the motion
and
and you know
when you go through your first 10 plays
you might script 10 or 8 plays what have
you and then go walk through them in the
hotel or wherever you're at and you kind
of go through them two or three times
and
but look he was excited to be in that
spot and
i think for me
and for us it was a little bit more
about
how the game plan might vary
defending jameis winston versus taysom
hill and jameis
who had played in that game prior and
helped us beat
uh
i think it was we played the chargers
then
um
where jameis came in to finish uh you
know those are two different uniquely
skills the quarterback skill sets of
those two are much different
how much of the playbook is currently
available to taste them and how has that
changed over the last few weeks
well i'd say it's changed over the last
few weeks and so that there's there's no
just
oh monster playbook that sits out there
it kind of sits in
in the computer screen somewhere and
plays it you know i mean there's certain
run designs that we'll try to feature
each week but
um
but yeah i think our job is to is to
build this around what he does well
and you know we think he has a live arm
we think he throws the ball well down
the field we think obviously he can run
and he can run real fast
um in
but the thing that i think he did well
last weekend and it was the
the first real opportunity two weeks ago
was an aberration when we played out in
denver and that's not a a real good game
to even begin to look at
but i thought he handled the third down
well in atlanta particularly i mean he
had about i think we ended up in eight
and nine or 13
but manny made some some really good
decisions and and throws uh against a
difficult third down defense and
ultimately in this league you're gonna
have to
be able to convert third and seven third
and eight
five yards behind the center in the
pocket and and he was able to do that
you've been doing this a long time you
now have 141 wins 79 losses i've looked
at the records of some of the other
coaches who have at least one super bowl
win and either are or will be in canton
do you think about that much at all your
legacy whether or not you're going to
end up with a bronze bust i assume it's
a motivation for anyone who coaches but
how much of that do you actively think
about
um i
not a lot at all i mean
i
look i still visit with with with
parcells on a regular basis i've got
some close friends that i've had a
chance to be a part of their careers
that made it to the hall of fame um i
certainly think about drew's legacy
because that's more real and right in
front of us and
but
i
i think i imagine there'll be a time
someday someday you look back on it but
i feel like uh i've got a lot of years
coaching in me here still and and
i feel like we've we've built a real
good program here
uh our ownership with mrs benson and the
front office group mickey loomis we
we've had a lot of stability i don't
take that for granted at all we've got a
passionate fan base i mean an extremely
passionate fan base
and we've got all those things that are
in place that a lot of dysfunctional
teams don't have
you mentioned drew what will be the
factors and who makes the call on when
he's able to return
oh i would imagine like anything else it
would be the doctors and the player i
mean honestly we'll
i know that you know we kind of stay up
to speed on it
um
there's a little bit with his injury of
like watching spaghetti boil where
you've got to let it heal and it's it's
a little different than maybe uh
soft tissue or bone bruise or something
specifically i mean
uh there's
there's x amount of time that's needed
this is the week he's eligible to be to
to come off of reserve injured and the
rule this year was if someone goes on
you know you're on for a three-week
minimum um
but each day we'll we'll get up
you know an update as to how he's doing
and then you know a lot of it is how
does it feel
um if you've ever like really thrown a
baseball a football or anything and then
you realize your rib cage and all the
soft tissue and muscles surrounding it
you know it's pretty painful and
that's the thing is to be able to
you know function without those
side effects or or things that might
hurt your play
this year has involved the tracking of
player movements both on and off the
field like never before tell us what
zebra technologies has going on to
better help teams and players understand
everything that they're up to
we're seeing it right now every time i
mean how many times during a broadcast
do we hear next gen stats and that's
zebra
and it's kind of cool you know my son
who watches all the games
they get more information than we ever
thought about getting you know attracts
the fastest play or fastest player of
the week you know we got to 22 miles an
hour and it's usually number 10 at
kansas city
and uh
and
then they'll they'll all of a sudden
you know give you more information as to
what personnel is on the field they can
handle a lot of the busy work all the
teams are are using zebra now we use it
for
uh to monitor our players during
training camp and
and it gives us
a lot of valuable information relative
to their workload but
the more and more we start tracking
information relative to the players and
each player has a chip the ball has a
chip and i i think mike we're slowly
moving to a spot relative to officiating
where
you know we're gonna we're gonna be a
lot more accurate with spots of balls or
or punts that go out of bounds in the
air there's just a number of ways that
the technology i think can help us
get us up to speed yeah we see it we see
it all the time just in a casual spot of
the football
and i think the fans
everyone involved wants that exactness
now and it's it's hard to do as an
official
so this is a technology that you know
basically it's no different than your
tracking system if you have an invisible
fence at home with a dog you know you
set up a surrounding perimeter
and then the chip inside of it all that
information is gathered and recorded and
then it's whatever you want from it
101 years of two sticks and 10 yards of
chain it's long overdue for something
better than that to determine where the
football is and whether it's gotten to
where it needs to be one more question
for you before i let you go and i know
you got a lot to do and i want to keep
this general i don't want to make it all
that specific we saw something over the
weekend that involved your former
defensive coordinator greg williams
where he calls in all out blitz late in
the game
and the head coach lets it proceed and
it makes me very curious especially when
you're an offensive coach and you
delegate the defense to your coordinator
what are the procedures what are the the
rip cords in place
if you see your defensive coordinator
doing something that you just flat out
disagree with and and you need to change
it is there a safeguard there to step in
when you have that well our delegated to
the coordinator no there's never that
much power delegated to the coordinator
if you don't want there to be that much
power delegated to the coordinator but
the communication has taken place well
before i mean in our game for instance
atlanta ended with them having the ball
i think 19 seconds no timeouts that
they're so in a
i think in a similar situation a little
bit i their field position
i don't know
well their field position got to
midfield where they could throw one into
the end zone the game ended on a hail
mary i'm talking about our game in
atlanta and i can only reference
how we do that and dennis is into utah
and i'm and and it's a personnel
grouping and i'm like dennis we're
defending the sidelines right yet
um and right away we're rushing three
and so there's this communication and
then dennis makes the call as to hey
because we're in that
gray area are they gonna throw a hail
mary here or are they going to throw one
to get 15 yards get out of bounds so
they get closer for a closer
shot to the end zone
um
but there's dialogue there's dialogue
well before the play
because there's a clicker on my headset
that goes to defense and then it goes to
offense and so look
i'm gonna i'm not gonna um interfere
with the
the voices in the terminology but i'm
clicking over and we're just making sure
we're on the same page here
um they've got to they've got to throw
for the sidelines they don't have any
more timeouts let's keep the ball in
play and we're going to win this game
and listen what happened there um
enough's been said about it uh
um
just crazy
that was the only thing the steelers
needed last night
i i i've i've been i've been watching
football for 50 years and i can't
remember a moment like it to me it's the
defensive equivalent of the miracle in
the meadowlands now it's not like it's
going to revolutionize defense because
everybody already knows how you play a
play like that
you just keep playing it like you always
used to it would be the equivalent of a
hand-off getting fumbled in an age where
everyone knows you go into victory
formation
yeah that would be a good a great
analogy that someone chose to
run a handoff when a knee was all that
was needed
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports